I'm a taxi driver De Niro yeah I meet
the is De Niro I'm watching you I'm
watching you who painted that mole on
your face did you do that yourself yes I
did yes I did that is actor Dave Franco
in the movie Neighbors which he stars in
with Zac Efron and Seth Rogen but Franco
is now focused on another passion
screenwriting he and his wife actor
Alison Brie wrote the new movie Somebody
I Used to Know Franco also directed the
film in the movie Bree plays Ally a
workaholic who returns to her hometown
and just happens to bump into her
recently engaged ex-boyfriend here's a
preview
hey Roger yeah
[Music]
Ally
Sean oh my God now were you just hiding
under the table
I was looking for my
um
peanut got it Dave Franco joins us first
on CBS mornings welcome thanks for
having me romantic comedies what do you
think what's the secret to making a good
one that is a great existential question
um I couldn't tell you exactly but my
wife and I we just love the genre and we
wrote this at the very beginning of
covid lockdown and at that time the
movies that we were watching were a
little more uplifting and positive and
we just looked at each other and we're
like let's put our own version of that
out in the world and try to spread a
little positivity you know I think the
keto romantic comedy is it has to be
romantic and also comedic yeah I have
that part down I think he got that part
down you nailed it man we see a lot of
your wife in this movie She's a Streaker
at one point yeah and you say it put
more passion back into your work life uh
are those things related well first off
yes so she she went to a progressive
liberal arts school where the rule um at
the at the University was clothing is
optional everywhere but the cafeteria oh
and so she just kind of streaked across
campus to make her friends laugh but
compared to some of the other kids you
know there was one kid who would show up
to all the art events only wearing
sneakers and a necklace and they
lovingly referred to him as the naked
guys she was tame wow I wonder what it's
like for you Dave because as I'm
watching and I've seen interviews with
Jay Williams who plays the love interest
here that he's Ellis J Ellis jail is
that he felt uncomfortable in some of
the scenes knowing that you're there and
you'd say no get a little closer get a
little closer how are you able to
separate because we see a lot of your
wife yeah I know it's called acting sure
but is there a part of you that's like
that's my wife right it's Jay Ellis yes
yes jail is from insecure we know him
and Top Gun it's it's very funny I've
realized on both of the movies I've
directed I have paired my right my wife
romantically opposite these very uh
handsome charismatic men uh but you know
what it's like we've been doing this
long enough it's something that it's not
like I'm I'm excited about the days that
my wife is being intimate with another
man but at the same time it's part of
the job and like we're all professionals
and it is called acting right yes and
sometimes scenes reflect your real life
sure how so
um let's see uh what can I say that
doesn't give anything away uh my wife
okay so she she sings these little
ditties throughout the movie She's um
just kind of making things up on the
spot and that happens on a daily basis
where I'll hear her across the house and
she's just serenading our cats uh and so
and then there's also another cat thing
um
uh are you know there's a scene where
the cat is
um defecating and puking on a plane it
happened to my wife that is a very funny
that happened yeah now listen this is
not your typical rom-com there's a lot
of funny moments but it also has a very
serious side yeah sure and I think that
also adds to the appeal of this movie
for me thank you yeah
um you know we we realize like I think
at its core I think the easiest way to
define it is a romantic comedy but we
realize while we were doing it it's like
oh this is more of an adult
coming-of-age story you know it's really
about kind of even the title Dave has a
double meaning to it sure yeah yeah did
you do that on purpose absolutely I
almost don't want to give that away if
that's all right the whole thing is kind
of about going home and reconnecting
with your roots and kind of confronting
who you used to be compared to who you
are now and how you feel about all of
that and
um kind of realizing like even if you're
not necessarily fully content with where
you're at it's not too late to Pivot and
go after the things that make you happy
can we talk about you and your brother
growing up was is this something you
both wanted to do to be in this business
I had no intention of doing this I was a
really shy kid growing and once I came
to LA to go to school I kind of got
forced into an acting class and I
remember auditing the class the first
day and the first people on stage
they're screaming and crying and hitting
each other and I was like no no no no
this is not for me but like I stuck it
out because I've just always loved
movies and I guess I've felt that this
was maybe a path into it when you saw
James do it did you think I want to do
it too or no no not at all and I just
never I'd never performed in any way I
was so nervous but you were you worked
in an old school videotape movie rental
shop growing up right right yeah like
that means that's a guy who loves movies
yes teenager yeah so I was 14 years old
it was my first job I was working at a
mom-and-pop video store and it was
actually illegal for me to be working
there at that age so they they basically
paid me by allowing me to take home as
many movies as I wanted and so that was
like my film school it was breaking the
law in a good way directing his wife my
partner would not want me directed it's
so funny because a lot of people are
like how is that they say it in kind of
a skeptical tone which is more
indicative of how they would imagine
working with their own part right you're
like I'm sorry for you and your
relationship but for whatever reason it
works it works it's like we I I truly
like I've always known she was a great
actress it worked well since I've been
in a position where I've been able to
watch her intently for months at a time
I realize she's one of the best Dave
Franco somebody I used to know can be
streamed on Amazon's Prime video
starting Friday it's good